in the six months before she took her
own life Molly Russell engaged with more
than 1200 posts on Instagram which her
family say promoted or encouraged
suicide or self-harm
today an executive from the company
defended its policy but in a heated
exchange at the inquest into Molly's
death her family's lawyer asked why on
Earth do you do it
he shouted you are not a parent you are
just a business in America you have no
right to do that the children who are
opening these accounts don't have the
capacity to consent to this
Elizabeth Lagoon who heads well-being at
meta responded this is an evolving field
meta said it is right that people should
be allowed to make admissions or
expressions of suicidal and
depression-related thoughts as that may
help get others to reach out to them and
gives them a sense of community
Molly's family's lawyer suggested
Instagram focuses on the benefits to the
person posting content rather than the
risks to Children engaging with it in
court meta described much of that
content as nuanced and complex to deal
with and said it had expanded its
policies since Molly's death to include
graphic content and fictional depictions
of suicide and self-harm
Ms Lagoon told the inquest she's proud
of where Instagram's policies are now
and then went on to apologize for Molly
seeing content that violated its 2017
policies
Molly's family say children remain in
danger because social media companies
are still not doing enough Sadia
Chaudhary Sky News in North London